brady quinn joins us and uh he'll be
with rob
stone reggie bush matt leinart urban
meyer every saturday they start at 10
a.m eastern on
big noon kickoff and fox sports college
football pre-game show nebraska at ohio
state this saturday brady joins us
from columbus brady i'm going for
ratings here
and you know i'm sure your voice is
decent but we were looking for a little
eye candy today so
i'm disappointed that you're just
joining us on be a phone and not a zoom
call so would you apologize to uh the
audience about especially our our women
are you know the ladies who are watching
[Laughter]
well here's the thing is i've got to do
something to drive the rating
to our show big noon kickoff tomorrow at
10 a.m eastern as you just said
uh and so i'm actually just trying to
tease everyone and all those listeners
with the entire audience
at the dp show to tune into big noon
kickoff so that was the actual strategy
from all this
okay yeah yeah do you think that maybe
i shouldn't be on camera i should be
just teasing people with my voice
to listen to it um
i i think you've done this long enough
where people can kind of i think i think
they know what they're getting with the
voice
right i think they know what to expect i
mean i grew up watching sportscenter
highlights with you so i can vividly
remember you back then
now everywhere in between so well thanks
for joining us brady that's all i wanted
to talk to you about we appreciate you
joining us
perfect thanks for having me all right
uh does it feel like this is really
this is this is happening this weekend
this is columbus this is the ohio state
they're playing football
i am standing in the shoe right now and
uh
kind of looking at just the the
differences
of obviously it's an empty skating but
there's going to be a few cool things i
think they're doing
uh for the fans for us here fox sports
from what i'm looking at right now
uh but also the student athletes and
then some of the students so
they're trying to make the best they can
but it is now feeling like it's real
it's feeling like this is finally gonna
kick off tomorrow
you know at noon the big ten coming back
which look in my opinion
uh is going to be a big player right i
think the ohio state buckeyes are going
to be a team that's going to be playing
for the national championship
uh when it's all said done i think the
only if is more about the schedule of
the big ten
not having any room for air even with
daily testing and looking at their
protocols
just some of the hurdles they may have
to you know get over or jump over
just to make it to the national
championship game in regards to cove
i think that's my biggest concern with
this ohio state buckeyes team so you
think covet is the biggest obstacle for
the big ten
not you know playing football and then
not playing as many games as the sec or
acc like
ohio state wants to play or the big ten
wants to play for the national
championship
how is that possible i think an
undefeated
ohio state penn state whoever would end
up being
would have as good of a case as any of
the other schools
you know especially if they have a loss
or two in there
um but look i think you you need you're
going to have the top four teams
you know play off for this and if you're
looking at the criteria we've already
seen in prior years
the committee not necessarily utilize
their own criteria they've created you
know we've seen teams that haven't won
their division have won their conference
still making the college football
playoff so i think they'd be willing to
in a year like 2020 given all the things
we've had to adapt to and adjust to with
covid
i think they'd be willing to allow a
team that maybe didn't play as many
games
but when undefeated in their conference
looks dominant be a part of the college
football playoffs
you can't have a close game it feels
like it feels like you know that margin
of victory is coming back to college
football at least during this season
well yeah you look at notre dame they
beat you know louisville and i know the
conditions weren't great last week
and i think there are some people who
are like kind of put off by the fact
that like they won they were just
concerned by
by how much um and so no that i think
that's the day and age too now of just
us
trying to determine who really are the
best teams and we look at the way they
dominate teams
in order to get some sort of inclination
as to what they are
and i also think you know you look at
like clemson for example where
they're they're going to be better than
almost every single team they play and
line up against
um and then favor be a heavy favorite in
almost every game
and dab with swinneys obviously wants to
get some of those younger guys some
talents and
you know some time to go in there and
play in the second half of games so when
they do move on from trevor lawrence
they've got a quarterback who's waiting
in the wings who's got that experience
but unfortunately i just think in in
today's college football world when you
only have four spots to play for a
national championship
you do have to do everything you can to
prove that you should be one of those
top four teams
especially if you drop a game and so
that's kind of the unfortunate reality
now that we're in with the college
football playoff
and also we're seeing early in the
college football season that you don't
have that home field advantage without
the crowds that we've seen
teams on the road come in and steal some
victories here
how do you think that's going to impact
the big ten
i think it's going to be exactly what
we've seen the other power 5 conferences
um you know you kind of talked about
that i think one of the reasons for a
margin of victory
and what we're seeing with disparity
between teams is just
i think with the really really good
teams can take advantage of some of the
continuity that they have
with returning upperclassmen or guys who
are experienced and showcased themselves
and for those that don't necessarily
have that they don't have a bunch of
returning starters on either side of the
ball
they're going to struggle i mean they've
obviously been limited with not being
able to have any spring practice
training camp was you know was
interrupted and that's where you kind of
get to a point where you look at
some of these games where they get out
of hand you're like well well no crap
and obviously
some of these teams have dealt with cove
it differently than others i think the
other thing is
they needed more of that practice time
college football is a developmental
sport
and so that plays a factor but there's
no doubt um not having
you know home field advantage is gonna
hurt i think some of these teams
especially anyone who plays ohio state
it's gonna be a lot harder to think that
they're gonna go on the road
and potentially you know fumble or
stumble along the way
uh when you don't have the ability to
have that 12th man in the crowd
compare and contrast trevor lawrence and
justin fields
well i'd say this i mean trevor lawrence
has already kind of
you know has the equity built in
considering what he's already done in
his career
i don't know that i have any questions
about that young man's ability to throw
from the pocket his athleticism his
toughness
his football iq if you will from
everything we've seen i
just don't have any questions like
there's really he can't really go much
higher in my mind and he really can't go
much lower to be quite honest with you
with justin fields i think it's the it's
the opposite where
he got better as last year went on
especially from the pocket and that's
some of some of what you want to see
some of what i would like to see from
him though is running a little bit more
you know that's one of his skill sets
that they didn't utilize a lot last year
because they were worried about what was
behind him
if he got hurt and he ran too much you
know now gunnar hoke their backup
he's he got a little more experience so
he can come in and spot work and they've
got two really talented freshmen
uh who are behind him stroud and mills
both kind of waiting in the wings
so a little bit different scenario so i
think you may see him run a little bit
more
early and often this year for ohio state
and that's one of the things that
i'm curious to see how dynamic he can be
as a runner that's some that at college
and obviously the nfl level now you got
to be able to do
the heisman does it feel like it's a
lifetime achievement award for trevor
lawrence
yeah but you've seen other you know
years where guys have wanted it's been
kind of like that i mean let's be honest
it's usually going to the best player on
the best team
i mean that's the reality of the award
uh and i think there's certain years
where you know maybe you don't have one
dominant team uh and you've got a player
who put up a lot of great stats and he's
been
you know good throughout the course of
his career and he ends up winning it and
and look i i hate i don't authority
names out there because i think when you
do that
then people think it's like a diss to
them but in all reality
you know he's he's gotten himself to
kind of be in that heisman conversation
every year
so there's there's a lot of respect for
that but i i think it would be
if he was if he was going to win it this
year it kind of would be but he's also
earned it to some degree he's played
really really well this year
he didn't get off to a slow start like
he did last year daniel jones had the
mishap last night what's the most
embarrassing moment you had on the
football field
man i would say
i was rolling out to my left this is
2009
first game of the year for the cleveland
browns i was rolling out to my left
and i i literally am as i'm kind of
scrambling and flushed out of the pocket
i i go to like separate my hands through
the football and literally
the ball just kind of came out the back
as i was starting to bring the ball up
to throw just slipped out of my hand
and i can't remember if we got the
fumble back or not i remember trying to
and all that but
when the ball slips out of your hand for
some reason like that is the most
deflating
thing as a quarterback because then
everyone starts questioning like your
grip
and your you know hands a hand strength
hand side like all those things
that was probably one of the more
embarrassing things outside of the
plethora of
uh marketing deals that i did wait
marketing deals yeah advertising deals
like go check out the one oh did you do
a lot of the one the shirtless ones
no no i i maybe had one somewhere
somewhere along the lines in there but
uh i think there was one there was a
subway one we did
and i i'll never forget uh they had
they'd shave
both uh joe thomas in our head it's like
kind of that that rookie
hazing initiation whatever we're gonna
call it and uh i had to do this subway
commercial and i think i was like it was
like a happy gilmore scoop like i was
like throwing subs to people
off some float i remember thinking back
on that
going this was not something i should
have agreed to at that time yeah but you
know
always 20 20. what polly yeah we got it
it's brady on a float outside the
stadium and he's got a crew cut
he's throwing foot longs to people in
the band he hit the trombone guy on us
you know out pattern you know i have to
say that the trombone guy actually had
great hands there was actually
someone else too who had uh i think they
had some of a trumpet or something like
that they had made a great one head
together
who can throw it farther you or liner
who threw it throws it farther right now
right now
or if reggie bush can throw it farther
than you i don't know so out of you guys
there oh no
his his shoulders are banged up it would
it would be without a doubt me
although he's probably been throwing a
football a little bit more often because
his son cole
he was a great little little youngster
little quarterback coming up in the
ranks but
uh i i would definitely say me well
actually i've actually been still
keeping in shape working out you know
so what do you what you can throw at 60
uh yeah i'd say pretty safe right now
we've got a little bit of wind
too so i'd probably be wanting to throw
towards the tunnel where the team comes
out but yeah
what about uh urban meyer no
no i champ i think reggie wins that
battle oh
wow i think rob stone might win
wow and rob stone's a soccer guy man
okay
all right hey have fun tomorrow and uh
great to talk to you again
we appreciate you joining us as always
always fun being on thanks for having me
dan
that's brady quinn used to play for the
cleveland browns
played at notre dame and he'll be part
of the fox pregame show it's rob
stone rob stone a former intern at the
mothership
and now he's hosting he's a big time fox
guy with reggie bush matt liner urban
meyer
every saturday at 10 a.m eastern on big
noon kickoff
it'll be ohio state the ohio state and
hosting nebraska and uh coverage starts
at 10 a.m eastern
from the horseshoe